five las vegas raiders star henry ruggs
arrested accused of a fiery and deadly
dui crash the latest from the scene and
reaction from the raiders
breaking his silence superintendent
jesus jarrah issue in the first
statement since his firing his message
for teachers
76 degrees weather now winds are calm as
well and cooler than yesterday while
warn your forecast straight ahead
this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
we are following breaking news here off
the top at five a las vegas raiders star
accused of causing a deadly crash on a
local road this video from a neighbor
shows the fiery aftermath early this
morning
this news reaching around the world
today cutting through the sporting world
and the las vegas community and a good
evening to you thank you for joining us
on eight news now at five i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez we have
team coverage tonight joe moeller has a
closer look at henry ruggs the young man
accused in that crash chris matthews has
reaction from the raiders we start with
victoria saha with what we've learned
about this tragic crash victoria
the roads here are back open it took
police more than 12 hours to examine the
scene and take the person who died out
of one of those burning cars
and we are learning that she was a
23-year-old person now this early
morning crash shook up this whole
neighborhood
metro police confirmed ruggs was driving
his chevrolet corvette when he hit a
toyota rav4 the rav4 was traveling north
on south rainbow by spring valley in the
right lane at the same time police say
ruggs and a female passenger were in his
corvette going fast in the center lane
then veered off to the right lane that's
where the rav4 was the front of rug's
car hit the rav4 from behind when the
rav4 came to a stop it caught on fire
when first responders got on scene they
found the driver of the raft four dead
she was 23 years old amy rigo lives
right in this area she provided eight
news now with the video of the rav4
catching fire i don't know if anybody
had time to take whoever was in there or
what or they were scared because you
know corona whatever but i really felt
bad that
you know i feel like
maybe if somebody wasn't just not afraid
could have went out there and helped
them metro police say ruggs stayed on
scene after the crash and showed signs
of impairment he was taken to umc with
non-life-threatening injuries
ruggs was released from the hospital and
taken into the clark county detention
center he is due back in court in court
excuse me tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
victoria saha live local now